ازمه في معسكر بلجيكا وحقيقه هدف رونالدو
ومغادره حارس الكاميرون وبنزيما يثير
الجدل هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على
العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد ما انتشرت احاديث عن مشاكل ومشاحنات
في معسكر المنتخب البلجيكي وتحديدا بين
هازر وفرنسون خان عقب الخساره امام المغرب
خرج هذا ليا في الامر معلقه لم يحدث شيء
في غرفه الملابس كل ما تم نشره من خلافات
واشاعات هو هره واضاف بدعابه لست غبيا انه
اضخم مني لافوت معه بجدال
منذ امس ولا حديث لعشاق كره القدم سوى
الجدل حول هدف البرتغال الاول في شباك
الاوروغواي هل سجله رونالدو امبرونو
فرناندو
اغتصب في البدايه لرونالدو لكنه سحب منه
لاحقا واحتسب لبرونه الشركه المصنعه للكره
اديداس خرجت ببيان صحفي لتحسم الجدل
الكبير رونالدو لم يلمس الكره بعد عوده
الشركه للحساسات الموجوده داخل الكره
والتي تعمل بدقه عاليه
غادر حارس انتر ميلان الايطالي اندريه
اونانا تشكيله منتخب الكاميرون نيمو
مشاركه في كاس العالم وذلك بسبب الخلافات
مع مدرب الفريق والاتحاد الوطني لكره
القدم وشهد اليوم في المطار في قطر وكان
عنان قد استبعدا من مباراه الجوله الثانيه
من دوري المجموعات لكاس العالم ضد صربيا
لاسباب تاديبيه في ما نفع حارس المرمى ان
يكون قد تصرف ضد مصلحه منتخب البلاد
نشر قريب بنزيما صور اليوم لوصوله الى
جزيره ريونيون حيث يقضي فيها اجازته بعد
استبعاده من المنتخب الفرنسي بداعي
الاصابهصور مرفقه بالرقم تسعه سبعه اربعه
لترهل اليوم التساؤلات على مدرب المنتخب
الفرنسي ما اذا كان سيعود لتشكيله الديوك
ام لا يجيب دي شام لا اشغل بالي به حاليا
ويعني بالطبع كلب بنزيما
[موسيقى]